hello everyone sorry about uploading a
video so late had to drive my girlfriend
to the hospital it's nothing serious but
it's always nice to be supportive so
here we have a game from round 10 of the
2013 candidates tournament and it's
really really a wild game it's Oregon vs
vastly von Schuch and since it's vastly
von Schuch you know that there there's
gonna be action on the board and before
we check out the game we don't have a
lot of photos from this game only one
and it's a it's it's a photo from
somewhere in the middle of the game I
went to made this move he's returning to
the board nothing out of the ordinary
Magnus Carlsen is checking about the
position as he is always interested what
he von Schuch is playing and we do have
the standard hidden thermos bottle by 11
Arnhem so that's it by the photo and now
on to the game and it's very interesting
that there will be a link in the
description below you can check out
other nice article by Peter Dodgers
about roms 1011 Arnold said about this
game that he knows that vastly won't
replace anything and everything and it's
really a waste of time to prepare
something for vastly mantric as you
really have no idea what he's going to
play so instead Aragon prepared nothing
for this game you know he just kept a
clear head and you know whatever happens
happens and he was he was correct
because what if entre played in this
game is I mean you wouldn't expect to
find this in a you know I don't know
some mediocre tournament let alone in a
candidates tournament so let's see this
game
Aragon opens with d4 and again I blunder
with wood to the sound sorry and just
have to take care of that
ok d4 Knight to f6 c4 and here it is
event took place only 5 the budapest
defense d captures on e5 and now Knight
to g4 we have Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and the Avenger goes for Bishop to f4
sorry Aragon goes for Bishop to f4
Bishop to b4 check this is the
Rubinstein variation over the Budapest
gambit and that's why I put the
Rubinstein a port above the board it's a
very nice quote probably one of my
favorite quotes and also there will be a
little surprise
but I will I will say more about that
after the game so Bishop to b4 check
Knight to c3 Bishop captures pawn
captures and Queen to e7 we have Queen
to d5 and now comes the immediate f6
it's very interesting instead of this f6
move there is a very famous game between
Akiba Rubinstein and dr. Mullen vidmar
where dr. Mullen will vidmar played
Queen to a3 and I will also show you
that game but I will not analyze I would
just show it to you after this game so
if anyone is interested in expanding
their vast knowledge you know you were
welcome to check it out it's quite a
wonderful King hunt but in this game
eventual goes for the immediate f6 we
have 8 captors on f6 Knight captures on
f6 attacking the Queen and Queen goes
back to d3 we have d6 and g3 now if I
took castles Bishop to g2 Bishop to g4
and Aragon castles so Ireland managed to
castle tuck he tucked his king away to
safety and he still he still up upon
it's not a pawn you know you want to
show your friends or brag about it it's
a CC pawn but still up it's a pawn up so
rook 88 even goes for the e2 point we
have rook 81 yeah Aragon defense it came
to h8 and night to d4 Aragon would be
very happy if e1 took would capture here
so he can under his pawns and I do have
to notice that a lot of you are saying
that I'm pronouncing onion incorrectly
but I don't think that's that's really
true because I don't know the official
commentators who who completely
shouldn't know how to pronounce it
pronounce it that way so I mean if you
really sure about it do give me some
link or something but I really think I'm
pronouncing it correctly either way we
have Knight to e5 of course the eventual
doesn't want to capture on d4 Bishop
captures D characters on e5 and not nice
to f5 attacking the Queen Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Knight
to d7 attacking our announce Queen Queen
back to e4 and now C 6 C 6 is a move
that wasn't really necessary and could
could pose event
in the near future
Knight to c5 was maybe a better move but
you know who could know such things we
have rook to d1 nice to b6 and now rook
to d3 Arlen has some nasty ideas of
maybe playing Queen to h4 at some point
after the Queen moves pushing g4 and
then how would this nice rook lift to
bring the rook over to h3 so so he can
attack the black King we have Queen to
c5 a bunch of piles up on that c4 pawn
as it's a it's a very weak pawn we have
Queen to h4 Aragon proceeds with its
plan and here it's very interesting
Aragon of course it's very hard to
defend this double pawn and there's
really no point in doing that but can
you want to capture it if you want you
can capture this pawn then he would
equalize in material and he would have a
better pawn structure so he would have a
better position the problem is if you
play Queen captures then Aragon would
exchange Queens and after Knight
captures rook to d7 is coming and white
gains so much activity it will be very
hard very hard to keep to keep your pawn
structure now you don't have to bring
your knight over to the edge of the
board or you have to play a passive move
like rook to b8 white white white will
simply be better here
on the other hand instead of Queen
captures you could also capture with the
knight but if you play Knight captures
then rook is coming here immediately
and then after something white can
easily already make a lot of threats
towards the black king and the black
would not back willing to enjoy this
position very much so after Queen to h4
g6 by von Schuch and this is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
the idea is at some point this night
we'll be able to move and then rook to
the 7 will not be such a terrible threat
because g6 will be blocking any any
immediate attacks towards the black king
so Bishop to e4 immediately iron and
threatens Bishop captures on g6 as the H
pawn is pinned so
ink to g7 now the King is also guarding
the pawn King to g2 and now comes Queen
captures on c4
now if I took figures out that okay it's
pretty that's too bold of a plan Arnon
just
you know started and it's okay to grab
the pawn rook F to d1 Ireland doubles up
on the D file and E one shook considers
it's it's okay to grab even another
point and that that is in fact so he
plays Queen captures on a2 and now comes
G for iron and proceeds with this plan
if any of you had an idea maybe rook to
d7 sacrifice the exchange for some nice
attacking ideas maybe even a checkmate
with Queen here it doesn't work because
after rook to f7 the Queen from a2 is
also protecting into rock on f7 so there
are there are no rook captures and Queen
captures on h7 ideas so after Queen to
a2 we have g4 now there's this threat of
rook coming to h3 rope to a four by one
choke attacking the bishop here and we
have Bishop to f5 a very nice piece
sacrifice
although the pea sacrifice cannot be
accepted as now when our a nun played
Bishop to a5 the rook is no longer able
to go back here so if you did capture
the bishop with G captures here then
rook to d7 would be deadly there's
really nothing for you to do here you
have to capture and after captures you
have to give up your queen with Queen to
f7 if you don't if you move your king
then Queen that captures on h7 will lead
to the checkmate so you would have to
give up your queen and have to row
capture screen captures you don't have
to rooks against the Queen but the two
rooks are are too much you know they're
really not coordinated precisely and a
white white will win this endgame so
after this Bishop to a5 event to play
Knight to d5 and this is the best move
again recommended by the engine but the
problem is a year again for divine cook
this is only moved 27 and Avenger has
only 2 minutes on the clock so once
again
Chucky's is in time trouble we have rook
to h3 now threatening Queen captures on
h7 and here would h5 event you can still
play this position as of course pawn
captures is impossible the pawn is
pinned
rope capture screen will be coming but
even to plate look to h8 here III was
played and this is only move 29 but
already now event rubies in a very
of position the only move he can make
here to the keep playing this is
actually rook captures on f2 and after
Queen captures royal Queen captures and
after King captures G captures on f5 so
given up the exchange but again it would
be very hard to play this after white
captures Knight captures on c3 rook d7
is coming with check and then the Queen
side points will start dropping so after
this III move event was really low on
time and he played G captures on f5 and
the problem is after he went to play
this this is only moved 29 he had one
second on the clock so one second on the
clock to play 11 more moves to reach
time control which is of course
impossible
Aragon could literally just play Queen
captures on h7 any watch would not have
enough time to reach time control and he
would lose in time but of course he
didn't Aaron and he's a gentleman he
played he captures on f4 and here lastly
when she lost his fourth game in this
candidate tournament candidates
tournament on time he was in time
trouble almost every game I believe one
game he wasn't but this is the fourth
game in this tournament he lost on time
so something is terribly wrong and the
one who really didn't either enjoy this
time control or he didn't like that
there was no increment in the first hour
and a half of play or or he who knows he
may be prefers the old format where you
had two and a half hours before you had
to reach down control it's very hard to
say
but yeah after he captures on f4 you
want to be lost on time and Aragon you
know closes the gap nicely towards the
Magnus Carlsen who is leading this
tournament as we will show one more game
from this round we will not show the
standings just yet but one more game is
coming and then we will show the
standings after round 10 so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it lastly I
mean playing the budapest gambit in the
candidates tournament that is that is
amazing stuff but unfortunately even
though it was it was a great game he
spent too much time and in the end it
cost him the game but like I said we do
have something special after this Queen
to d5 movie once you've played f6
so that's basically it for the
game if you know if you wanna stop
watching the video now but for those of
you who maybe want to expand your vast
knowledge there is a very nice miniature
played like we said between Akiba
Rubinstein and dr. millaa millaa and
Widmer who also played the Rubinstein
variation of the Budapest gambit against
the Rubinstein himself the game was
played in 1918 and here as we've said
instead of f6 dr. Emil and Widmar played
the Queen to a3 attacking the c3 pawn
here look to see one was played the
bishop is guarding the rook we have f6
pawn captures a knight characters and
Queen to d2 now these six we have night
to d4
we have castles by V admire III by
Rubenstein and Knight captures on d4
silk captures on d4 and Knight to e4 now
attacking the Queen Queen to c2 and here
comes the move that starts one oh one of
the nicest King hunts I've ever seen
we have Queen to a5 check King to e2
moving the King away from check as the
knight is guarding these squares so King
to e2 and now comes Luke captures on f4
pawn captures on f4 and Bishop to f5 now
there are threats of knife to g3 opening
up a discovered check and the bishop
will win the Queen here so Queen to be
two now comes rook to e8 again Widmer is
threatening all sorts of discoveries
King to f3 getting the King out of the
way but again it's not something I mean
your king is on f3 here we have a knife
to d2 check by vidmark the knight is
guarded by the Queen and the rook is
controlling the entire efile so you
can't really do anything here you have
to go go to g3 Knight to e4 check yet
again and here Arobin I should have
retreated with King to f3 but for some
reason he thought that it's okay to play
King to h4 and he did but now I mean
your king is on h4 and it's a very nice
position as in the real game Aragon
versus event we didn't have any
mysteries for you to solve so feel free
to pause the video here and find the
forced checkmate in five and beat Akiba
Rubinstein
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations I mean you just
you're you're an excellent player and
for those of you just want to enjoy the
show here dr. Mullen Widmark played rook
to e6 which is of course as you see the
knight and Bishop are creating a nice
wall here so the King can go anywhere
rook to h6 will be an immediate
checkmate so the only defense a bishop
or Queen to e2 whichever piece you
prefer to give up
rook to h6 check Basha blocks and now
comes Rock captures on h5 this is with
check King captures and now comes Bishop
to g6 in this position
Akiba Rubinstein resigned the game but
it doesn't matter even if the King goes
to h4 or g4 Queen to h5 you had to see
this that the Queen can also join the
action Queen to h5 will be checkmate so
yeah just a nice little game I wanted to
include in this game because it's the
budapest gambit i mean we have to we
have to enjoy some of the classics as
well so yeah i do hope you enjoyed both
of these games and for the end i would
like to thank Johan Aleph Brian Rivera
Gary McGowan and Barry when live and for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it and Gary
McGowan is is actually a 50 year old
player for 50 years and he's rated over
2200 so I'm very glad that you know even
stronger players and the long long-term
tournament players that are enjoying my
channel so as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another game from round 10 of the 2013
candidates tournament thank you all and
I'll see you soon